what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back once again with another episode
of our beyond omega level series where
we break down the most powerful
characters and comics and today we're
focusing on roon king thor who is
arguably the strongest version of thor
that we've ever seen in comics right up
there with king thor or herald of
galactus thor the donny case recently
introduced of course thor's been around
for decades first appearing in journey
into mystery number 83 by stan lee jack
kirby and larry lieber in 1962 but this
version of thor comes from a story arc
that serves as a prologue to the
avengers disassembled storyline and ran
from issue 80 to 85 in the mighty thor
written by michael ohming in 2004 and
you guys will actually find a link to
that video down in the description just
to set the stage of what's going on with
thor at this time his father odin had
basically been killed during dan
jurgen's run on thor by the fire demon
surter making thor the lord of asgard
and he was a terrible king the reason
why i say this is thor does a lot of
questionable stuff like trying to take
over earth fighting with and imprisoning
the avengers and marrying amor the
enchantress he just basically lost his
mind thor and amora end up having a son
named magni who grows up and doesn't
approve of how his father has run things
so thor finally realizes that he's made
a mess of everything and decides to undo
all his mistakes using time travel now
after all this is undone thor faces a
new threat as loki brings cerner back
from the dead in an attempt to bring
about ragnarok the final battle of the
asgardians and the destruction of asgard
now sirder ends up using the forge where
mjolnir was created to create more
hammers made from the same uru metal
that mjolnir is made of now loki also
assembles a team of some of thor's
greatest rivals including eulek the
troll herm the giant and loki's own son
fenris wolf now while thor is in the
davalier the realm of the dwarves to pay
respects after the deaths of two of the
realms finest blacksmiths along with
siff amore balder and the warriors iii
loki's forces basically launched their
attack using the hammers that surter had
made now during this melee mjolnir is
broken as it makes contact with ulik and
fenris hammer simultaneously thor's then
nearly killed by loki who blast him into
the waters inhabited by the midgard
serpent but thor manages to escape to
midgard and then enlist the help of iron
man and captain america now thor returns
to find asgard completely in shambles
and he and his allies are quickly
ambushed by loki's forces this time
however thor's able to gain the victory
with the help of captain america and
iron man as ulik and herm the giant are
killed and loki's forced to retreat with
the rest of his forces now thor then
finds out that both his mother frigga
and his brother balder have both been
killed and after sending iron man and
captain america back to earth he
journeys to alphein the realm of the
lighthouse and there he finds volstack
but learns the other two members of the
warrior three have also been killed now
later beta ray bill shows up to help
thor and kills fenris wolfe prompting
loki to once again retreat but try as he
might thor can never seem to get the
better of loki so he basically leaves
bill to rule asgard instead and then
tries to figure out what he needs to do
and so thor is visited by a ghostly
young kid that has odin's two ravens
with him and it turns out this boy is
actually the personification of the odin
force which is exactly what it sounds
like the force that gave odin his powers
now this kid tells thor that he needs to
gain wisdom if he's ever going to really
live up to his potential and that in
order to gain this wisdom he needs to do
what odin did in his quest to gain this
wisdom and so thor goes to the well of
mimir where odin gouged out one of his
eyes in an attempt to gain wisdom but
this is not enough and the boy tells
thor that he needs to go beyond the
sacrifice odin made so thor gouges out
both of his eyes as well as drinking
from the well which enables him to see
into the past and discover that ragnarok
is actually a cycle of destruction and
rebirth of asgard that repeats itself
throughout eternity and so after that he
goes to the lifetree idracil where odin
had previously hung himself for nine
days until he was nearly dead once again
needing to outdo odin's sacrifice thor
hangs himself in the tree until he dies
but in the process he gains knowledge of
rune magic which is not really explained
in much detail but what we do know is
that it gives him knowledge of basically
everything that will come to pass in the
future and so thor finally succumbs to
death and wakes up in health but before
his soul's claimed by hela odin's spirit
ultimately rescues him now the next time
thor wakes up he finds himself in front
of those who sit above in shadow which
is really a council of divine beings
that are seemingly vastly more powerful
than the gods of asgard and so you can
think of them as gods to the gods one of
the funny things about this is that
during the last days story arc following
or at least leading up to the events of
secret wars loki talks about the ones
who sit above in shadow and alludes to
the fact that they might be beyond us
people like to take that and say see
they're beyonders loki doesn't say
they're beyonders he says they might be
who knows nobody knows nobody knows what
they are but what thor figures out is
that their power is derived by the
endless cycle of ragnarok a cycle which
thor vows to break and so when he leaves
the presence of those who sit above in
shadow thor's armed with both the odin
force and rune magic which results in
him being
ridiculously powerful and so the first
time he puts this on display is when he
encounters one of his strongest foes the
man gog now the man gog is the last
surviving member of a race that
attempted to invade asgard but the
invasion fails and odin imprisoned man
gog beneath asgard where he stayed until
he was freed by ullah the troll and the
man gog has always proved to be one of
the most challenging foes that thor has
come across and every time man gog is
defeated he later reappears i mean
literally the man gog is like the only
thing odin is afraid of in this instance
rune king thor does not struggle with
man gog at all and like easily defeats
this guy simply just by touching him
like he it actually like erases the man
god from existence right so this guy
like ruined king thor he was a
multiversal being it was insane how
powerful he was but after defeating the
man gog thor sets his sights on loki and
after easily destroying loki's army of
trolls he gets his hands on loki and
then pulls his head off now loki's head
continues to speak after being separated
from his body and thor basically carries
it with him as he seeks out certain to
repair mjolnir now in exchange for
repairing his hammer thor offers certain
a free path to asgard for one final
battle and so thor then makes his way to
the tapestry of fate which basically
contains the very threads that make up
reality with the intent to destroy it so
the cycle of ragnarok will be broken now
those who sit above in shadow appear to
thor and implore him not to destroy
reality even going so far as to offer
him a seat on their council but thor
refuses their quest and destroys the
tapestry along with idracil and those
who sit above in shadow with one swing
of his hammer literally thor destroyed
reality with one hit of his hammer now
once ragnarok is over and asgard and the
asgardians are all destroyed thor enters
a state of hibernation similar to the
odin sleep before being brought back to
the marvel universe around two years
later now unfortunately this really
is all we've seen out of rune king thor
as he's only been around for a little
over one issue and hasn't been heard
from again but the fact that he
displayed the ability to remove the man
god from existence and destroy reality
with one hit implies that he was at
least able to teleport others across
dimensional barriers and perhaps even
warp reality itself which would actually
make sense as he was described as having
the ability to know the past to see the
future and to control the present and
the fact that he was able to take out a
council of beings that were more
powerful than the gods themselves and
just caused them to stop existing shows
us that we're dealing with a
ridiculously powerful individual which
is probably why we haven't seen thor tap
into rune magic and become rune king
thor since this time as it just makes
him too powerful to tell a compelling
story but let me know what you guys
think down in the comments right i mean
this guy this version of thor was
ridiculously op there is a part of me
that kind of wants to see him come back
but in all the years that i've been
reading through i'll be honest with you
guys in all the years that i've been
reading thor right jason aaron's run
i've read walt simonsen's run i've read
dan jurgens run i've read all these
different runs on thor i have never seen
a version of his character as powerful
as this like what is it like thor in the
mcu right when he's got like like
stormbreaker no man he pales in
comparison to this guy but i love this
version of thor right we don't get to
see him long but i do love this version
of thor because he's just so
ridiculously overpowered but with that
being said guys let me know what you
think down in the comments section i've
been meaning to do this video for a long
long long time
nathaniel from patreon don't worry i
will do your video on parasite explained
i've been meaning to tell you that we're
gonna do that video don't worry i'm not
gonna leave you hanging but thank you
guys for watching and i will catch you
all later peace